hey everyone I'm yessi and welcome to my
kitchen today I wanted to have a bit of
a different style video I just wanted a
sit down video no editing no scripting
just to chat with you about a recent
video that I posted I recently talked to
you about why I was quitting my
full-time job my college career as a
nurse in order to pursue slow living and
be able to be a stay-at-home mom
specifically to homeschool and in this
video I really wanted to dive deep into
my experiences as a hospice nurse the
things that I've learned the ways in
which it's changed my life and to sort
of allow that to be a time to reflect
back on a phase of my life and allow
myself to emotionally just come to
acceptance and be able to close that
chapter in my life to start a new one
hospice nursing is something that has
completely changed myself my perspective
even my family relationship and
relationships that I have with other
people it has completely transformed my
life just being able to serve people
that are at such a critical stage of
life I think it's been something
completely amazing and so I wanted to
share some experiences with you that
have shaped me and before I actually
begin I just want to let you know I you
might hear some Footsteps in the
background and some kids talking again
this is a sit-down chat video you are in
my kitchen and they are in the living
room so you just we're just all going to
be one big happy family today
um but the first thing that I wanted to
talk about is why I decided to go into
hospice nursing and what is hospice
nursing I have been blessed to have had
the opportunity to be a hospice nurse
for three years and before that I was in
ICU nurse and ICU and hospice are
completely different Realms in ICU I was
trying to do anything and everything to
save someone's life I was putting tubes
and Visually every orifice in order to
be able to keep someone alive hospice
nursing was completely different when I
was in ICU I thought that hospice nurses
were just there to take patients away
and take all their medicines away and uh
that was completely not the case I had a
completely different vision of what
hospice meant and I had a very negative
vision of what hospice was until I got
to experience it firsthand so why I
decided to go from ICU and to hospice
nursing is I have always been very
passionate about human dignity from
conception in to death and even after
death that we just still deserve dignity
and the way that we're buried and and
the way that we're honored I just I feel
very passionate about we have value as
human beings and I wanted to treat every
single person that I had as a patient
with love and compassion whether they
were a drug addict or whatever they came
in for I didn't care I felt that that
person was important and they were my
VIP whenever they were my patients
um that being said I was seeing so many
things that just didn't settle well with
me in my heart and I I couldn't quite
make sense of them
um from elderly patients that had had
what's called a DNR they didn't want to
be resuscitated they they wanted to just
be made comfortable have a natural
passing
I saw some family members keep them
alive for the checks that they were
getting from them oh that hurt that hurt
me emotionally
um I saw other things that I just I
couldn't unsee we were not respecting
the Dignity of those human beings and
even my final straw my cherry on the top
was a doctor
uh who who desperately wanted to keep a
patient alive after a procedure
not because he heard about the patient
but because he cared about his mortality
rate doctors have a mortality rate and
he wanted to preserve that
and um the wife had been seeing him be
resuscitated and all these things that
we were doing there's so many people in
the room she was distraught the daughter
was distraught she was seeing this
happen
and she says stop
I mean it must have taken everything in
her to say stop let him go
and the doctor says continue CPR I'm
gonna go talk to her
he talks her out of it she must have
felt like the most horrible wife in the
world to have even wanted to stop CPR
and so we continue eventually passes
anyway
but this to me I I couldn't deal with uh
just the fact that we weren't giving him
dignity we weren't taking care of this
wife and this daughter
he was more concerned of his mortality
rate that was more important
um
than the human beings that were present
in that room and seeing this and the
life that they would carry afterwards or
the guilt that that wife would have for
wanting to stop CPR
we weren't treating humans like humans I
felt like um and and this is not to talk
negatively about ICU because I loved
when I worked in ICU I mean there were
so many times when I just I could
experience Miracles people that we
didn't think were gonna heal would heal
um I had an amazing experience as an ICU
nurse and I am so happy and thankful
that I got to be God's hands and feet
that in that area
but there were so many things that I I
just I couldn't deal with and that
experience really was it was it when
that happened that day and I could see
that woman's face and the daughter and
and the look of their their faces seeing
CPR happened and even having the
strength to say it's okay let him go
Batman was very very ill
um
I couldn't do it anymore I wanted to
work in something where I could preserve
the Dignity of human beings and
um it so happened that that very evening
I met somebody that was a hospice nurse
and started talking and um
I ended up saying I would give it a shot
and so I applied and I had been
since then a home nurse within hospice
and it was completely different so the
patients that didn't want to be in the
hospital anymore that have gone through
chemo and therapies and things that that
were just absolute torture for them that
they didn't want to do that anymore
could go home and I had so many
incredible experiences in hospice
nursing
that I I think if I spent time talking
here this video would drag on forever
but I I wanted to First explain why I I
switched from ICU into hospice nursing
um
and then to talk about
those experiences hospice nursing is
something that has completely changed
the way that I view life and who I am as
a person because every single day that I
present to work I'm faced with the
concept of death and dying and this
realization while to some people can
make them feel helpless and hopeless
to me it has had the completely opposite
effect because I realized that no matter
whether I want to or not I will leave a
legacy behind and it's up to me to
decide what I want that Legacy to be
and even though maybe when I was 17 the
idea of eventually quitting my job would
be exciting or the thought of it would
be exciting
I'm honestly sad uh that I'm going to
miss this
precious time that I get to have with my
patients
even though 80 of my job is more of like
driving to their homes and medicines and
speaking with doctors and things like
that that time that I spend with those
patients and their families at their
most vulnerable state is is precious and
it has given me so much it's taught me
so much and honestly I feel like I've
gained so much more from them than I
have ever given or could ever give to
them some of the most difficult patients
for me to deal with just emotionally
mentally spiritually is um when
a patient doesn't have any more options
available that they want them
oh that to me is crushing absolutely
crushing I never want to admit a patient
on the hospice when they want to fight
for life but there's just nothing more
that can be done for them I remember I
spoke about it in a different video I'd
still remember the two-year-old little
girl that had brain cancer and she'd had
all these different procedures and there
just wasn't anything else that they
could do and these patients not these
patients these parents
they were incredibly strong incredibly
just
I'm not going to say at peace because
it's something that is a huge struggle
that they probably still struggle with
today
but just the fact that they were so
loving and so supporting even up to that
moment it was incredible and it's
something that I never wanted to be a
part of especially with children because
an adult can have this process of grief
and acceptance and bargaining you know
the stages of grief but a child doesn't
understand
why they're suffering and why they're
struggling they can't put those pieces
together they just know that they're
suffering that to me is is the most
difficult is dealing with children and
babies oh my goodness I just I never
want to do that adults it can also be
really difficult for me when they've
been in shock
when I just recently had a patient that
kept complaining of pain kept
complaining of pain and just odd
symptoms here and there and then all of
a sudden he goes he gets these scans and
he's got cancer everywhere
and by now he's got three months or less
to live and he's just in shock it is
incredibly difficult for a family to
assimilate that this individual was fine
and then from one day to the next and
all of a sudden they're on hospice and
they're gonna pass soon
and to be able to be that person to be
with them to say you have options you
have resources this is what we can do
for you Counseling Services all these
different things that they have
available
um it is difficult but it's also a huge
blessing to be able to be there with
them and to guide them through that
process I honestly feel like the
patients that I've had are just absolute
Heroes without capes but they are
absolutely strong and courageous and
they teach me so much
um about humility and love and service I
recently had a patient a pancreatic
cancer patient
that is an absolutely incredibly painful
cancer and every time you would eat it
would hurt so it just wouldn't eat
and he offered to grill me barbecue
because that was something that he
really enjoyed he enjoyed grilling
before and he enjoyed serving other
people and helping other people and I
just
my skin just shivered when he offered
that to me because I realized
you are the one that I'm supposed to be
serving and yet you want to serve me
just
what an incredible demonstration of
humility and love and it makes me think
in my personal life do I serve like that
do I serve the people around me with
with this kind of love the
self-sacrificing love and in a different
video that I had I made a short about
this one
this individual just completely touched
my heart because he was selling his
truck and he was so weak because he had
just gotten home from the hospital but
he wanted to make sure that that was
done so that his wife was taken care of
so that she didn't have to deal with all
these things after this passing and the
fact that this was the final thing that
was representative of him his truck that
he was proud of that he had finally
obtained and fixed and he was letting go
and accepting that he was passing but
also taking care of his wife in the
process like just ah the love that
poured out of this man for her in this
instance
and I could just give you so many
examples of people that
in the midst of their hurting they're
worrying about their family and how
their family is going to be and even
just serving complete strangers like me
it makes me
realize
that I have taken my life for granted
that there are so many things in my own
life that I don't appreciate as I should
the fact that I can breathe okay that I
don't have lung problems and
I can just take a deep breath when some
people are literally struggling to take
every single breath that they take it's
painful
they feel like they're suffocating
the fact that I get to walk when some of
my patients that have cancer are just so
weak I think that as a 20 something year
old I can often forget that my life is
counted my days are counted and that I
should be grateful for every single day
that I have and live it fully to love
the people around me and take advantage
of the opportunities that I have
and that was one of the things that kept
replaying in my mind when I was thinking
about do I quit my job or not is that I
felt like I was being stretched from
Every Which Way and trying to do so many
different things at once and I remember
a verse in the Bible talking about you
can't serve two masters without failing
one and I'm not one that ever remembers
versus so I'll let you look up that one
but I just kept hearing it over and over
again and thinking I'm trying to manage
my households taking care of my kids
trying to educate them trying to have a
full-time job and trying to serve a
church and trying to grow a YouTube
channel and doing so many different
things that I felt like I wasn't
actually being fully
present with the things that I was doing
because I was just focusing from doing
one thing to the next to the next to the
next
and I was getting burned out and
despite the lessons that I learned
despite the incredible service the
hospice has been to me
I felt like it was time for me to apply
the things that I had learned and
to take that leap to quit that job that
is providing our main source of income
our only stable income our only
Insurance source and to go all in on the
thing that brings me a lot of passion
which is this YouTube channel and
educating my children at home which is
something that I'm very passionate about
I recognize that I have been needed in
the home with my family and that's
something that I need to do more of and
quitting my job was the only way
I still feel like hospice nursing will
always be a part of me whether that's
through volunteering or other methods
because I don't want to forget that I am
vulnerable that I am a human being that
these experiences aren't just them and
their own experiences and their own
suffering that I can also experience
that
and at some point I will
and
not to be afraid of that but instead to
let that be the thing that empowers me
in order to live my life in a way that
when that time does come
I can be happy and at peace because I
know that I gave the best that I could
give that I loved as much as I could
love and I served
and that I gave myself without fear and
that I did the things that I wanted to
do without fear that I was going to fail
and even if I was afraid I still did
them anyway I still took chances that to
me
would be a life worth living I also want
to talk about the fears that I've had in
regards to transitioning from full-time
working to being a stay-at-home mom
because a lot of people talk to me about
like oh my gosh you get to retire and
how cool for you like you must be so
excited and I am I am I'm incredibly
excited and thankful of the fact that I
get to have the choice to homeschool my
children I know a lot of people don't
even have that choice and they would
want to it is a huge blessing that my
husband is willing to
but there are a lot of things that cause
fear and cause anxiety if I listen to
them so of course there's the money
aspect and wanting to be free of
financial worries and struggles going
from having our only stable income and
losing that for my husband's somewhat
iffic income because he works in
construction it's Hit or Miss sometimes
there's construction is good and
sometimes it's not and losing our only
Insurance Source yeah it can cause a
sense of fear because we had stability
before or we thought we did and now
losing that it can make me feel
uncertain
um being a person of faith it makes me
realize that I'm not the one in control
and I don't need to worry about that
because no matter what I'm going to be
taken care of and my needs are going to
be met
um specifically in the Bible there's a
verse again I'm not somebody that
remembers verses you can look that one
up but it talks about even the Birds
don't have to worry about being fed
every day so why do you worry when I
know every single hair on your head
that's counted
I may not go exactly like that but
that's what I remember and it helps me
it helps me to remember that it's okay
my needs are going to be mad I don't
need to worry about that but the other
aspect of fear that I have had to really
process through is something that was
very internal that I didn't realize had
been changing inside me to better
explain that when I first got pregnant I
remember feeling a sense of fear
because I had a lot of
I'm gonna ruffle some feathers here but
I had a lot of feminist uh ideologies
that were hurting me I felt that if the
man was the one taking care of the home
and I didn't have my own income then he
was under control or over control and I
would be subject to him and that if I
got pregnant and I couldn't work then I
would lose my power
and
I'm saddened that I I had those thoughts
and those fears about something so
beautiful as being a mother and being a
wife because I have an incredible
husband
I was recently reading or listening to
the book The empowered wife ah it is an
incredible must read I highly recommend
it for anybody that is married or is
wanting to get married is in a long-term
relationship highly highly recommend it
but I had a lot of fears about being
vulnerable
and I now see that allowing myself to be
vulnerable allows my man to take care of
me
to have a reason to fight and to
struggle for me and he does it with love
because I am coming from a place of love
and compassion and appreciation for what
he does for me and by doing that we have
come together I have definitely embraced
my femininity a whole lot more and I
felt so much more empowered by it rather
than what I ultimately feared was that I
would be vulnerable and that that would
make me weak but realizing that it is
okay to be vulnerable in the arms of a
man that loves you and that is willing
to fight and protect you and your family
it's incredibly freeing and
strengthening and an odd way to explain
that's that's something that I could
just rant on about another video
so that's just what I wanted to share
with you just my thoughts and insights
and mainly just to give an opportunity
to let you know that if you are changing
phases in life it's okay our life has
phases and rather than trying to swim
past them rather than trying to break
through them and rush them to embrace
them so for example when I became a new
mom I had so many anxieties and fears
and worries and I was trying to rush to
the next phase
I could just have embraced it and
recognize that it was going to pass I
would have been so much happier and now
as I'm progressing from this fast phase
of being a full-time working mom to
being more at home and having my own
projects
that it's okay to embrace that and not
be afraid especially as I mentioned
losing our only stable income and our
only Insurance Source it can definitely
cause a sense of anxiety and fear but
it's a phase it's a phase and we'll get
through that and I think that if we
could just Embrace whatever phase of
life we are in now
and figure out the way to live it more
fully and love the people around us
passionately and then we would be all
the more happier
so that's it for today's video it feels
like it was more of a rant and I hope
that it wasn't I I hope that you gain
something valuable out of it that it was
helpful for you and I also hope that
once I have kind of given myself a few
weeks to kind of transition into
homeschooling mode that I'll be able to
post videos more frequently so if you
have any suggestions recommendations
things that you would like to see in the
future be sure to let me know in the
comments below or send me an email I
thank you so much for watching this
video and for sticking to the end and
I'll see you in the next one bye for now